there are financial crises now all over
the world jobs gone livelihoods lost but
here in Lebanon it is on a different
level this is a snapshot of a country
broken ileus is a father on the move he
isn't going far just from one street to
another the family belongings in the
trolley evicted from the old home are
now moving to the new one
and this is it this room and the kitchen
bathroom behind the eight of them
mandemus man that my father should copy
my muff you go ahead a bar maybe
delusion you're my favorite rod got
about chunky you know I'm pleased they
have already been told they need to move
on again in a month sixty percent of the
people in Lebanon could be below the
poverty line by the end of the year
sixty percent and that is the view of
the country's own economy minister
Beirut's main public hospital is named
after the former assassinated Prime
Minister Rafik Hariri one of generations
of leaders who have consistently run the
country through mismanagement and
corruption they're giving us a tour to
see their challenges so the the ER
Department is now just for Corona Corona
is of course a huge concern
they had contained it but now the
numbers are rising fast the problems
here though go well beyond the virus in
the neonatal intensive care unit they
want to try to show us that they're
still coping but the drugs imported from
abroad and now unaffordable are
literally running out so the major
problem at the moment is the lack of
material and this is not only at our
hospital but it's it's worldwide
medicine you mean it will soon not be
possible to care for babies like Shireen
born with brittle bones and in the most
desperate of states in another Ward a
father with his daughter who has
leukemia they have the drug she needs
for now the power went down last week
and the generator back up to the
hospital manager is consumed by it all
we are really so much on the
on the brink of you know we are working
with so many shortages that it will be
very difficult to pinpoint a certain
services I think that all the services
that we are providing at the hospital
are in danger back in the neonatal ICU
this is the sort of victory that keeps
them going a little boy very premature
but he has defied the odds breathing now
on his own that's a good news story yes
success story but still in order to
treat and care for these children
you need the equipment you need medicine
and that's hard to get right now that's
hard to get given the financial the
financial crisis and the number of
patients that we are accommodating at
the hospital Beirut central square was
packed with hope last October but the
People's Revolution came to nothing
Sammis or habe is an economist but a
citizen too just trying to make ends
meet the amount of loss is actually
estimated by the government and the IMF
to be around a hundred billion dollars a
hundred billion yes and this in a
country like Lebanon that now expected
to have a GDP of 33 billion dollars this
year it's three times the size of the
economy and this is quite gargantuan and
quite you know I I personally don't
think there has been something of this
size in the history of modern economies
there are just two hours of state
electricity a day here now even the
traffic lights are out the politicians
who caused all this and now pleading for
an international bailout without it the
collapse of a nation is closed mark
stone Sky News in